nuevas restricciones para viajeros que
lleguen a francia en un intento de
frenar la propagación de las variantes
de coronavirus los pasajeros
provenientes de brasil argentina chile
sudáfrica y la guayana francesa tendrán
que hacer una cuarentena de 10 días se
llevarán a cabo controles en los
despegues aterrizajes y en el lugar en
el que se hospeden los viajeros en
territorio francés las medidas han
desatado reacciones diversas entre los
viajeros provenientes de buenos aires
a mi edad creo que es bueno me siento
más a gusto no sabemos si será efectivo
es preocupante para aquellos que tienen
que vivir con las consecuencias los
pasajeros también tendrán que entregar
una prueba pcr negativa realizada a
menos de 36 horas antes del vuelo o una
llevada a cabo hasta 72 horas antes más
un test rápido de kobe realizado en las
24 horas previas al vuelo bajo las
nuevas medidas sólo los ciudadanos
franceses los residentes o quienes
posean pasaporte de la unión europea
tendrán permiso para volar a francia
los vuelos con brasil se encuentran
actualmente suspendidos las variantes
brasileña y sudafricana actualmente
representan solamente el 4 por ciento de
los casos en francia aunque este experto
cree que las nuevas
serán cruciales para mantener bajos los
casos donde sería difícil de entender
que lo impusiéramos medidas de
cuarentena para un tipo dos cientos de
miles de pasajeros provenientes de esas
áreas donde las variantes son
potencialmente peligrosas ahora si no se
detienen esas variantes podrían desatar
una cuarta una infancia en pocos
desarrollo si es posible pronto otros
países podrían ser añadidos a esta lista
el gobierno francés ha dicho que india
podría ser el siguiente